the u.s is not alone in facing a surge
in coronavirus cases there have now been
more than 18 million confirmed cases
around the world
recent spikes have forced many
governments to shut things back down
or reconsider their plans for the
immediate future
elizabeth palmer reports from london
in australia's second largest city
melbourne the streets overnight were
deserted as the government declared a
state of disaster
life here had been close to normal again
until a sharp spike in covid cases
now in this city of 5 million only one
person per household can go out to shop
and police are enforcing an hour a day
limit on exercise and a strict
dusk to dawn curfew where you slept last
night is where you'll need to stay for
the next six weeks
premier daniel andrews said you will be
stopped and you will be asked and you
will need to demonstrate that you are
lawfully out and that you are not
breaching that curfew
in europe too there's been an uptick of
covid the french has set up testing
stations at
airports and so have the germans though
over the weekend there was pushback
right-wing demonstrators fed up with
restrictions marched
in berlin demanding what they called
their freedom
in saudi arabia the annual hajj to mecca
would have sent covid cases
skyrocketing so the government slashed
the number of pilgrims allowed from more
than
2 million last year to a cautious spaced
out
ten thousand only the moscow authorities
look out of step
with roughly the same number of new
coveted cases as melbourne
they let a half marathon go ahead the
nine thousand runners would be
encouraged to social distance they said
which worked out about as well as you
might expect
it's now been six months since the world
health organization declared coronavirus
a global health emergency and just this
morning its head
said there is no silver bullet to stop
it
at least yet jeff okay liz thank you
very much a rising
number of schools delay plans to reopen
as coronavirus cases increase ahead what
superintendents across the country told
us about keeping children safe